18 meses después de su cierre causado
por la llegada del cob y 19 los teatros
de broadway se preparan para la
reapertura de sus puertas al público un
momento especial y emotivo para los
actores que se sienten aún un poco
oxidados por no subirse durante tanto
tiempo al escenario el itesm está bien
en fenómeno extraño va a estar frente a
una audiencia y en su momento me parece
que fue lo justo sabes quiero decir todo
era tan aterrador durante la pandemia y
era una especie de sensación de alguna
vez la vida volverá a la normalidad
assange nuevos
el musical conforme way cuenta la
historia sobre un pueblo canadiense
pequeño que recibió siete mil pasajeros
varados después de que su avión fuera
desviado a raíz de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre
una historia apropiada de solidaridad y
compasión 20 años después de los eventos
traumáticos que sacudieron el país y la
ciudad hasta los huesos
el momento es perfecto el aniversario
número 20 del 11 de septiembre y la
reapertura de broadway específicamente a
nuestro espectáculo que habla del 11 de
septiembre y de la comunidad miraría los
teatros comenzaron su apertura a
mediados de abril en nueva york pero
broadway permaneció cerrado ya que los
teatros esperaban que las restricciones
sobre la capacidad se levantarán con la
mayoría de los principales musicales
incluyendo a hamilton y el rey león' que
retomarán la próxima semana los artistas
están ansiosos por estar de nuevo bajo
los focos del escenario